lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
analizar cómo describir la posición en
una dimensión como función del tiempo
digamos que x es la posición de una
partícula como función del tiempo y
podemos definirla como t al cubo menos 3
t al cuadrado más 5 esto es válido para
valores positivos del tiempo porque
sería extraño tener tiempos negativos al
menos por el momento ahora veamos qué es
lo que describe esta función para
ayudarnos vamos a hacer una tabla para
registrar que cuando tenemos cierto
tiempo en segundos la partícula estará
en cierta posición del eje x cuando el
tiempo es 0 x de 0 es igual a 5 cuando
el tiempo es 1 x de 1 es igual a 1 - 3 +
51 menos 3 es menos 2 + 5 estrés para el
tiempo te iguala 2 x 2 es 8 menos 12 más
5 que es igual a 1 y para el tiempo te
iguala 3x de 3 es 27 - 27 más 5
regresamos a 5 esta tabla nos ayuda
qué es lo que sucede durante los
primeros tres segundos dibujamos el eje
x que luce así aquí está el cero
aquí el uno aquí 2 3 4 y 5 ahora veamos
cómo se mueve la partícula sobre el eje
x según la descripción de esta fórmula
comienza aquí y la partícula se mueve
así 1 2 3 vamos a repetirlo 1 2 3 el
movimiento que hago con el puntero del
ratón suponiendo que estoy contando bien
los segundos es el movimiento de la
partícula en el eje x podemos graficar
esto así comenzamos con el tiempo te
iguala 0 el tiempo está en el eje
horizontal y la posición que está en el
eje vertical pero aquí ya es igual a la
posición sobre la recta x y quizá esto
pueda parecer extraño ya que aquí
estamos hablando de la posición en la
dimensión de izquierda a derecha y en la
gráfica lo estamos indicando en la
dimensión vertical pero la gráfica
describe lo mismo entre igual a cero la
posición es 5 cuando t es igual a 1 la
posición es 3
continúa moviéndose cuando t es igual a
2 llega a la posición 1 después cambia
de dirección y en el siguiente segundo
la partícula regresa a la posición 5
algo interesante para pensar en el
contexto del cálculo es preguntarnos
cuál es la velocidad en cualquier
instante del tiempo recuerden que la
velocidad es la derivada de la posición
vamos a escribirlo la velocidad como
función del tiempo es la primera
derivada de la función posición con
respecto al tiempo que en este caso es
igual a la derivada de esta función aquí
aplicamos la regla de las potencias y
otras propiedades de las derivadas y si
no están familiarizados con esto los
invito a que revisen el material que
tenemos en caná académico al respecto
así que esto es igual a 3 t al cuadrado
menos 6 de +0 y volvemos a restringir el
dominio para valores de t mayor o igual
a 0 ahora podemos graficar esta función
de la velocidad que luce así veamos si
esta curva tiene sentido mencionamos que
el movimiento ocurre en un segundo 2
segundos 3 segundos comenzamos con el
movimiento a la izquierda
la convención es que el movimiento a la
izquierda se representa como una
velocidad negativa y el movimiento a la
derecha se considera como una velocidad
positiva en la gráfica vemos que la
velocidad se vuelve más negativa cada
vez hasta llegar a un segundo luego
sigue siendo negativa pero se vuelve en
menos negativa cada vez hasta llegar a 2
segundos y a partir de este tiempo la
velocidad se vuelve positiva esto tiene
sentido porque a los 2 segundos es
cuando la velocidad cambia de dirección
a la derecha la velocidad comienza
siendo negativa se vuelve más negativa y
luego se vuelve menos negativa hasta
llegar a este punto en donde cambia de
dirección justamente esto es lo que
vemos en la gráfica algo que debemos
tener presente cuando pensamos en la
velocidad como función del tiempo es que
la velocidad y la rapidez son dos cosas
diferentes la rapidez es igual a si la
vemos en una dimensión es igual al valor
absoluto de la velocidad como función
del tiempo o también podemos pensar en
la rapidez como la magnitud de la
velocidad como función del tiempo así
que al principio aunque la velocidad se
vuelva más
la rapidez incrementa la rapidez e
incrementa a la izquierda luego la
rapidez disminuye conforme la partícula
va más lenta y luego la rapidez
incrementa cuando la partícula se mueve
a la derecha más adelante resolveremos
algunos ejemplos de esto para
comprenderlo mejor el último concepto
que veremos en este vídeo es el concepto
de aceleración podemos pensar en la
aceleración como la tasa de cambio de la
velocidad con respecto al tiempo la
aceleración con respecto al tiempo es la
primera derivada de la velocidad con
respecto al tiempo y ésta a su vez es
igual a la segunda derivada de la
posición con respecto al tiempo va a ser
la derivada de esta expresión aplicamos
la regla de las potencias y nos queda
que es igual a 6 t menos 6 y de nuevo
restringimos el dominio también podemos
graficar la aceleración aquí que es
igual a la aceleración como función del
tiempo cuando el tiempo es cero
observamos que la aceleración es muy
negativa es menos 6 y se vuelve menos
negativa cada vez hasta llegar a
volverse positiva en el tiempo de igual
a 1 esto tiene sentido
recordemos cómo vamos 1 2 3 no cambiamos
de dirección hasta llegar al segundo
número 2 pero recuerden que después del
primer segundo la velocidad de la
dirección negativa comienza a ser menos
negativa cada vez lo que significa que
la aceleración es positiva si esto los
confunde pausa en el vídeo y piensen
esto con calma la aceleración es
negativa luego es positiva y luego
continúa siendo positiva el objetivo de
este vídeo es dar una intuición de estos
conceptos en los próximos vídeos veremos
algunos ejemplos que nos ayudarán a
comprender mejor el estudio del
movimiento en una dimensión nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo